This video is sponsored
by the Casper Mattress.
In today's video,
we're taking a look at
what happens when you combine
super glue with
a warm borax solution.
The result will surprise you!
And I'm not saying that in the clickbait way.
I mean it surprised the heck out of me,
so it will probably surprise you, too.
[Captions by Mary V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
Here's the basic idea.
We'll dissolve some borax
into some hot water,
and then we'll add super glue to it
in increasingly large quantities.
We'll then watch what happens
when we introduce
a large quantity of our super glue
into the borax solution very rapidly.
First, let's get a pot of hot water,
and add our borax.
[Music]
Warm borax solution,
and an eyedropper full of
cyanoacrylate or super glue.
[Music]
The super glue catalyzes immediately
on contact with the boric acid,
and it comes out in
these really cool patterns
that just kind of look like
pieces of plastic floating through water,
or maybe pieces of coral,
or something organic.
I don't know.
It's really bizarre.
At this point,
they're also completely catalyzed,
they're not sticky anymore.
There's no super glue leftover,
it's just catalyzed plastic.
Not terribly durable,
it feels kind of hard,
but you can usually
just tear them apart
if you're determined.
We've seen that
the super glue turns white
when it hits our borax solution,
and I think we can add
a little bit of color
using some alcohol ink.
[Music]
You can see that it mixes in
quite well with the super glue.
It doesn't cause it to catalyze
or anything like that.
So, now let's see what happens
when we drip some of
the orange super glue
down into our pot.
[Music]
We definitely have managed
to dye the superglue,
and dye the plastic that forms,
and inject it down
into the borax solution.
You may have also noticed that
it was going a tiny bit slower this time,
and that's actually due to the heat.
It reacts a lot
quicker in very warm water,
and now this has been out here
for just long enough
to start cooling down.
To scale this up one step,
let's make a slightly
larger batch of our borax solution,
and then fill this tray.
I want to see if
we can draw cool designs
using the super glue
right into the liquid.
[Music]
It's not the prettiest
crown I've ever seen,
but it'll do.
The King of Random Crown,
a little bit different from
how we're used to seeing it maybe.
That really just looks like
crystal growth or coral or something.
We've got this big glass cookie jar,
and we're going to fill
this up with hot borax solution.
We're then going to dye some
of our cyanoacrylate glue,
and fill a small
water balloon with it.
We'll suspend that water balloon
underneath the borax solution,
and then pop the balloon instantly,
exposing all of that glue
to the borax solution around it.
This should be fun.
Guys, I want to take a quick minute,
and talk about Casper,
the sponsor for today's video.
We should be spending
one third of our lives in bed,
so why not make sure that
bed is super comfortable.
If you are looking to
upgrade your quality of sleep,
you can now get $50 off
of selected mattresses from Casper.
Just go to
CASPER.COM/THEKINGOFRANDOM
and enter promo code
THEKINGOFRANDOM.
The Casper brand mattress
is carefully engineered
with several types
of layered memory foam
to give you just the right
combination of support,
and sinking in.
Even though this is a nice,
thick, very squishy mattress,
they do manage to smash it down,
small enough that it fits
an impressively small box
when it arrives.
It is still a decent-sized box
because it's totally a mattress,
but it looks way too
small to be holding this.
When you're buying a Casper mattress,
you're buying directly from the company,
you're cutting out the middleman,
and you save on those costs.
You don't have to pay someone else
to be storing it in their warehouse,
and then showing it off,
and then all of the salesmen
fees and stuff like that.
You're just getting the Casper mattress
directly from the people who make it.
After you get your mattress,
you have a 100-day sleep on it trial,
which means you get to have
this bad boy for over three months,
making sure that it
is the mattress you love.
And if you don't like it,
they have a no-hassle free return.
Thank you to Casper
for providing my mattress,
and for sponsoring today's video.
Remember, you can now get $50 off
of selected mattresses by going to
CASPER.COM/THEKINGOFRANDOM
and entering the promo code,
THEKINGOFRANDOM.
I'm trying to use about a half
of the super glue in the one balloon.
[Music]
Perfect.
Okay, three, two, one.
No!
It didn't have enough pressure!
[Music]
Whoo!
Orange and pink.
[Music]
All right! Well, it's going
to have that much air in it.
Okay, so I'm going to put it under,
squeeze, and then stab it.
[Music]
Oh, that's amazing!
Little pockets of the glue got trapped.
It was just activating as they pull,
and leak their way forward.
A piece of my glove got glued
in place onto the balloon.
That, is the result of the super glue
catalyzing,
catastrophically,
and immediately with the borax solution.
It's kind of weird.
It feels as if you took
like thin plastic bags
and then melted it down into a blob,
so there's like really rigid parts
but then the edges of it are like very
flimsy-thin plastic still.
I'm trying to just tear it in half.
[Music]
Ahhh!
I dip it down into
the borax solution,
because I don't know
if there's gonna be bits of it
that haven't catalyzed,
and I don't want to get
those all over my hands,
and glue my gloves together.
Expands a lot!
That is way bigger than
the balloon I put down in there.
And this thicker portion is actually
the line along which the balloon ruptured,
So, we have it,
it tore open right here,
and right here,
and then these pieces were a little
slower to move out of the way,
as the whole thing expanded.
So yeah, you can sort of see
that egg shape of the balloon,
and then all the pieces
that erupted out of it.
That is a really cool reaction
with a really cool result.
You know looking at it,
I'm not sure if I like
the exploding balloon better,
or the leaking balloon better.
They gave us these
like cool snake things.
Both of them, I thought
turned out really well.
This first one with the orange plastic
didn't have the same
result as the second one.
That's because something
about the cyanoacrylate glue
makes the latex rubber of
the balloon not be very stretchy.
So, even though it was full
of liquid and underwater,
it didn't really have
any pressure to pop apart.
So, when I stabbed it,
it didn't rip open,
it just sort of started
leaking out of that one hole.
That's why for the second one,
I was actually squeezing
the balloon as I hit it with the needle.
And that made it
tear open all at once.
Guys! The fun is not over,
there's more for you to see.
That box up at the top will
transport you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box at the bottom
will show you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
And this bomb in the middle
will subscribe you to our channel
so you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.